we will now work with a geometric random
variable and put to use our
understanding of conditional pmfs and
conditional expectations remember that a
geometric random variable corresponds to
the number of independent coin tosses
until the first head occurs and here P
is a parameter that describes the coin
it is the probability of heads at each
coin toss we have already seen the
formula for the geometric PMF and the
corresponding plot we will now add one
very important property which is usually
called memorylessness ultimately this
property has to do with the fact that
independent coin tosses do not have any
memory past coin tosses do not affect
future coin tosses so consider a coin
tossing experiment with independent
tosses and let X be the number of tosses
until the first heads and X is geometric
with parameter P suppose that you show
up a little after the experiment has
started and you are told that there were
so far just 1 coin toss and that this
coin toss resulted in tails now you have
to take over and carry out the remaining
tosses until heads are observed what
should your model be about the future
well you will be making independent coin
tosses until the first heads so the
number of such tosses will be a random
variable which is geometric with
parameter P so this duration as far as
you are concerned is geometric with
parameter P therefore the number of
remaining coin tosses starting from here
given that the first toss was tails has
the same geometric distribution as the
original random variable X this is the
memorylessness property
now since X is the total number of coin
tosses and since your coin tosses were
all of them except for the first one the
random variable that you are concerned
with is X minus 1 and so the geometric
distribution that you are seeing here is
the conditional distribution of X minus
1 given that the first toss resulted in
tails which is the same as the event
that X is strictly larger than 1 so the
statement that we have been making is
the following in more mathematical
language that conditioned on X being
larger than 1 the random variable X
minus 1 which is the remaining number of
coin tosses has a geometric distribution
with parameter P let us now give a more
precise mathematical arguments but first
for a special case let us look at the
conditional probabilities for the random
variable X minus 1 and calculate for
example the conditional probability that
X minus 1 is equal to 3 given that X is
larger than 1 which is the same as
saying that the first toss resulted in
tails now the first toss resulted in
tails this is the probability that you
will need 3 more tosses until you
observe heads needing three more tosses
until you observe heads is the event
that you had tails in the second toss
tails in the third tours and heads in
the fourth dose and all that is
conditioned on the first toss having
resulted in tails
however the different coin tosses are
independent so the conditional
probabilities given the event that the
first toss was tails should be the same
as the unconditional probabilities
first toss does not change our beliefs
about the probabilities associated with
the remaining tosses now this
unconditional probability is easy to
calculate it is 1 minus P squared
because we have two tails in a row times
P now we observe that this quantity here
is the probability that a geometric
random variable takes the value of 3
here what have we calculated we have
calculated the PMF of the random
variable X minus 1 in a conditional
universe where X is larger than 1 and we
evaluated it for a value of 3 the
probability that our random variable X
minus 1 takes the value of 3 so what we
have shown is that this conditional PMF
is the same as the unconditional PMF now
there is nothing special about the
number 3 you can generalize this
argument and establish that the
conditional probability of X minus 1
given that X is strictly larger than 1
for any particular K is the same as the
corresponding probability for the random
variable X which is the t-one given by
the geometric PMF finally there is
nothing special about the value of 1
that we are using here in fact we can
generalize and argue as follows suppose
that I tell you that X is strictly
larger than n that is the first n tosses
resulted in tails once more
these past tosses were wasted but have
no effect on the future so the
conditional PMF of the remaining number
of tosses should be again the same
therefore the statement were making is
that this geometric PMF will also be the
PMF of X minus n given that X is
strictly larger than n and this will be
true no matter what argument we plug in
into the PMF
we will now exploit the memorylessness
property of the geometric PMF and use it
together with the total expectation
theorem to calculate the mean or
expectation of the geometric PMF if we
wanted to calculate the expected value
of a geometric using the definition of
the expectation we would have to
calculate this infinite sum here which
is quite difficult instead we're going
to use a certain trick the trick is the
following to break down the expected
value calculation into two different
scenarios under one scenario we obtain
heads in the first tours and in that
case the random variable X the number of
tosses until the first head is equal to
1 and this scenario occurs with
probability P and we have another
scenario with probability 1 minus P
where we obtain tails in the first toss
and in that case a random variable is
strictly larger than 1 now the expected
value of x consists of two pieces we
have a first toss no matter what and
then we have the number of remaining
tosses which is X minus 1 so this is
true by linearity of expectations now
the expected value of X minus 1 consists
of two pieces using the total
expectation theorem the probability of
the first scenario times the expected
value of X minus 1 given that X is equal
to 1 plus 1 minus P the probability of
the second scenario times the expected
value of X minus 1 given that X is
bigger than 1
now this term here is zero
why if I tell you that X is equal to one
then you are certain that X minus one is
equal to 0 so this term gives a zero
contribution how about the next term we
have a 1 minus P here times this
expected value now this random variable
conditioned on this event has the same
distribution as an ordinary
unconditioned geometric random variable
so this expectation here must be the
same as the expectation of an ordinary
unconditioned geometric random variable
and this gives us an equality both sides
involve the expected value of x but we
can solve this equation for the expected
value and we obtain the end result that
the expected value is 1 over P by the
way this answer makes intuitive sense if
P is small this means that the odds of
seeing heads is small then in that case
we need to wait longer and longer until
we see heads for the first time setting
aside the specific form of the answer
that we found what we have just done
actually illustrates that fairly
difficult calculations can become very
simple if one breaks down a model or a
problem in a clever way this is going to
be a recurrent theme throughout this
class